to me and I suspect to pretty much
everyone there's a difference between a
giant Burly dude and a pink mini skirt
and stilettos than say a woman wearing a
suit or even a man wearing a woman's
cardigan or women's skinny jeans
technically that all qualifies as
cross-dressing but clearly it's not all
as disruptive to society so my question
is do you really think it should be
illegal or just discouraged and if you
think it should be illegal how would you
define cross-dressing how would that be
enforced really really good question
Daisy I think that in the case of skinny
jeans skinny jeans should be illegal not
for cross-dressing just because they're
a hideous offense against style but that
that's a question I guess for another
time uh you you make a great point which
is that the line between cross-dressing
and avant-garde fashion can be a little
bit blurry I suppose that's true
nevertheless we can kind of know it when
we see it I think